in the world of One Piece there are
hundreds of different devil fruits each
granting the user's extraordinary
abilities in power but did you ever
wonder which devil fruits are the
absolutely strongest in the entire
series well you're gonna find out today
as we'll be explaining the top 20
strongest devil fruits in one piece and
let's start with the one most of you
probably forgot about the dokudoku no me
eaten by impel Down's Warden Magellan
this paramecia type devil fruit allows
Magellan to produce and control poison
and even Grant some immunity to it
although it sometimes looks like
Magellan can also transform his body
into poison like logia users that's not
really the case as he can only create
poison from his body and not transform
into it Miguel was shown using this
devil fruit in many unique ways like
traveling through prison by creating
poison tubes covering himself with a
thick layer of poison or using it as a
shield or even creating big monsters out
of poison such as hydras or demons
during the pre-time skip dokudokunomi
seemed Unstoppable and Magellan was able
to defeat many strong Fighters with ease
like Luffy and Blackbeard weird this
fruit doesn't really have any major
weaknesses but the user has to be
careful while using it next to his
allies as he could accidentally poison
them if he loses control number 19.
morimori no me morimori Nomi is a logia
type devil fruit that allows the user to
create control and transform into Flora
it was eaten by aramaki better known as
Admiral Greenville unlike most other
logia devil fruits this fruit turns the
user into a solid element instead of a
fluid this means that the user is unable
to let attacks pass through their body
though set attacks are still harmless to
them as they can simply regenerate from
wounds like any other logia in case the
user's entire body is destroyed at once
they'll simply regenerate by spouting
out of the ground like a plant during
combat greenbull utilizes this fruit
primarily to restrict targets either
wrapping Vines around them or capturing
them with underground root tentacles so
far the only known weakness of this
devil fruit is fire but even that can be
nullified as with enough training the
user can make his body fireproof
although we don't have much information
about this fruit as we've only seen
Greenville fight once it's certainly
powerful enough to earn a place on on
this list 18 more incredibly powerful
fruits are left and let's continue with
fire logia the metamera nomi metamera
nomi was initially wielded by Ace but
after his death it was eaten by his
brother Sabo in addition to the usual
logia abilities it also Burns an
opponent if they try to physically harm
the user While most other logius the
attack would just phase through this
devil fruit is really strong offensively
with the user being able to unleash
devastating Firebase attacks and use
Flames to increase the force of physical
strikes this is best seen in Ace's
signature fire fist attack which greatly
increases the size of his fist and turns
it into fire despite its aggressive
attacking power the metameronomi is
unable to win against certain other
logia powers like smoke or ice for
example as their Clash would just go on
indefinitely with no clear winner
however an even worse counter to this
fruit is akinu's magumugunomi which
completely overpowers it due to magma
being hotter than fire before we
continue there's one bonus double fruit
I'd like to cover the sub-sub know me a
special devil fruit that allows me to
make anyone subscribe to the channel go
on click it anyway the next up is Hobie
hobi Nomi a paramecia type devil fruit
eaten by Sugar that allows the user to
transform living people into toys by
touching them and erasing memories of
their existence from others as if that's
not powerful enough it also allows the
user to create a contract with the
victims forcing them to follow their
every order in addition victims appear
to lose their physical strength while
becoming toys being limited to the
capacities of whatever body they now may
have however if the victims were skilled
Fighters before becoming toys that
fighting knowledge is still retained the
user can take advantage of this by
commanding toys that were skilled
Warriors in their true form to protect
them although this fruit is ridiculously
powerful it has a few weaknesses for
example kill your knocking the user
unconscious will immediately cancel all
transformation and memory modification
effects also the user needs to be very
careful when creating contracts with the
victims as those can be easily exploited
via loopholes number 16. Zushi Zushi
Nomi Zushi Zushi Nomi is a paramecia
type devil fruit that allows the user to
manipulate gravity it was eaten by isho
better known as Admiral fujitora use
using this fruit's abilities fujitora
can move pretty much anything ranging
from debris to massive battleships the
range of this gravity field appears to
be incredibly big as he can even pull
down meteors from outer space fujitono
was also shown capable of canceling
Earth's natural gravity which allows him
to simulate flight we've seen this when
he made himself fly on a small rock and
levitate alongside his men on a ship
Fuji torah's signature technique during
combat is called gravity blade and using
it he can Channel gravitational forces
through his sword and unleash them
simply by moving his weapon he used this
during the dresserosa arc against Don
Quixote Pirates pinning them to the
ground and creating a huge hole however
even this power is not impeccable as
gravity can be disrupted by attacking
fujitore as shown when Zoro used a
projectile slash to interrupt the
Admiral enabling him to escape
additionally some people can resist
gravity if they're physically strong
enough to maintain a hold of their
current location I don't know about you
guys but it's crazy to me that there are
15 fruits left that are even stronger
than this one number 15. gorogoro know
me gorogoro Tony is a lokia type devil
fruit that allows users to manipulate
and turn into lightning it was eaten by
an l and according to Robin it's one of
the few Powers touted as Invincible as
pure lightning and Ellie's intangible
and can let most attacks face through
him harmlessly by fully turning into
electricity he can also move at
lightning speed allowing him to zip in
and out of sight cross large distances
instantaneously and overtake any fleeing
Target the most interesting thing about
this devil fruit is that the user can
even restart their own heart with
electricity should they need to even by
logia standards this route seems
remarkably strong possibly because of
the sheer destructive power of lightning
as an element while pretty much
Unstoppable the gorogoro Nomis abili
does have a unique weakness in the form
of rubber which makes whoever ate the
gum and gomonomi its natural enemies
Olive and L's lightning attacks had zero
effect on Luffy and Luffy's physical
blows could completely bypass anell's
intangibility another possible counter
to this fruit would be hockey but as an
L was a pre-time skip villain we don't
really know how effective hockey would
be against him number 14 Nikki
is a paramecia type devil fruit eaten by
the former warlord Bartholomew Kuma the
first and foremost ability of this fruit
is that the user can push virtually
anything they touch into bubbles this
includes both tangible things like
people and objects but also intangible
things such as Hollows pain and even
memories these bubbles can later be
stored and accessed by anyone who
touches them causing that person to feel
whatever was stored inside them we first
saw this when Zorro offered to consume
all of Luffy's pain from the bubble in
order to save his life this fruit also
offers the user an incredible defense
during combat allowing them to deflect
any attack they can also perform
offensive Maneuvers such as repelling
the air around them at very high speeds
these attacks are so powerful that they
can even leave paw-shaped imprints on
rocks one major weakness of this fruit
is that the user can only activate it
using his bare hands meaning if the
user's hands are occupied or is caught
off guard They will receive the damage
from the attack number 13. pika pika
know me next is pika pika Nomi another
logia type devil fruit that allows the
user to transform into light it was
eaten by borcelino better known as
Admiral kizario with pikapikanomi kizaru
can utilize light-based attacks such as
shooting laser beams from his hands
fingers or feet or even throwing
physical attacks that connect at light
speed which can cause devastating damage
however since the fruit is light based
all of his laser attacks can only travel
in straight lines same as light itself
Mike and Al his Auto can also travel at
the speed of light and instantly reflect
himself to any desired location using
this ability he can completely bypass
almost any attack even gunshots fired
from meters away if he for any reason
doesn't Dodge the attack it'll simply go
through him same as any other logia
power the fruits power can only be
nullified with strong hockey shown when
Rayleigh temporarily bypass Keys Auto's
intangibility and diverted his attack to
save Luffy and his crew number 12.ie no
me as the ice log yet this fruit allows
its user to transform into the element
of ice as well as creating controlled on
a massive scale for example aokiji can
freeze the surface of the ocean and then
casually ride across it on his bike he
could also freeze two tsunamis during
the the Marine Ford War saving the
Marines from whitebeard's Attack however
akiji's biggest achievement with this
power was battling Admiral akinu for 10
full days and permanently warping the
very climate of an island turning it
into a frozen uninhabitable Wasteland
although this fruit has many cool
abilities it definitely shines when it
comes to combat with aokiji being able
to create ice Weaponry or freeze his
opponents with physical contact he can
create enough ice to freeze a giant a
Sea Beast and even white beard
temporarily kiah Nomi is also one of the
few fruits in the entire series that can
prevent the user from drowning in the
ocean as the user can just create an ice
platform on the surface and stand on it
number 11. toritori no me model Phoenix
Tori Torino me model Phoenix is the
first mythical Zone type devil fruit we
were introduced to in the series and as
you can probably guess it allows the
user to transform into the Phoenix this
fruit was eaten by Marco the former
firstly commander of the Whitebeard
Pirates as with all zoens this route
grants Marco a significant boost to his
overall physical abilities and as a
bird's Owen Marco is also given the
ability to fly AI however the strongest
ability this fruit grants to the user is
to produce the blue flames of
Resurrection by cloaking himself in
Flames Marco can rapidly regenerate all
injuries inflicted on him much like how
a phoenix is said to rise from its own
ashes Marco can also spread the Flames
onto others around him helping them
recover from their injuries although to
a smaller extent although these Flames
can heal Margo from pretty much anything
there is a limit to it and therefore the
user is not truly Immortal with this
fruit covered we're only halfway through
the video and from here on the fruits
are going to get insane number 10. soru
sarunomi suru suruni is a paramecia type
devil fruit that allows the user to
interact with and manipulate human Souls
it was formally eaten by caramel and
later obtained by big mom this fruit is
without a doubt one of the strongest
fruits in the entirety of One Piece its
power of Soul manipulation consists of
manifesting and drawing out the souls of
people who feel fear the user can
extract the victim's Soul by grabbing
and pulling it out effectively stealing
the victim's lifespan another
interesting thing is that the user can
choose how much of a victim's lifespan
they want to take it's possible to steal
Decades of a person's life at once or
even just mere seconds another unique
ability of the Sodus orunomi is allowing
the user to infuse objects with soul
fragments granting them intelligence as
well as the ability to speak almost
anything can be infused with a soul
including plants food Furniture light
and even living animals big bomb refers
to these beings as homies and according
to her the more powerful the individual
the soul was taken from the more
powerful the resulting homie will be the
one major weakness of this fruit is that
its powers can be easily avoided if the
victim doesn't feel any fear towards the
user shoning Jim base in big mom's case
where she couldn't take jinbei's Soul
because he didn't fear her in the
slightest number 9. hito hito no me
model daibutsu hideo hido Nomi model
daibusu is a mythical zoen type devil
fruit that allows its user to transform
into Buddha it was eaten by sengoku the
former Fleet admiral of the Marines we
don't really have much information about
this fruit of sengoku used it only once
throughout the entire show but from the
looks of it it seems to be primarily use
for combat like other Zone devil fruits
hidohitonomi Grand sengoku incredible
physical strength and allows him to
contend with some of the strongest
fighters in the series when utilizing
this fruit sengoku's limbs grow out of
proportion giving him abnormally large
arms and relatively tiny legs while his
entire body takes on a solid gold Hue
during the Marine Ford War sengoku used
his buddiform to increase the power of
his punches and even launch golden shock
waves from his palms these attacks can
cause heavy and widespread damage to a
group of enemies and were strong enough
to injure Luffy and even the Blackbeard
Pirates number eight mugumagu no me
makumagunomi is another logia type devil
fruit and this one allows the user to
turn into magma it was eaten by sakazuki
better known as Fleet admirala kainu
even when compared to other logias which
are powerful in their own right the
magumugunomi possesses unmatched
offensive power which even the creator
of One Piece stated that if hakainu
wanted to find one piece you could do it
in one year same as aokiji akanu is also
capable of changing the climate of an
entire Island using his power turning it
into burning lands despite allowing most
of the attacks to harmlessly pass
through the user due to the fruit's
Natural element it can also seriously
burn anyone who tries to physically
touch a kainu and in some cases it can
also melt weapons that come into contact
with him I kind of prove just how
powerful this fruit really is during the
summit work where he fought against many
strong Pirates like Ace jimbei ivankov
and even Whitebeard his signature
attacking move is transforming his fist
into magma and sending it towards his
opponents he can also make multiple
magnifis and send them into the air
similar to volcanic eruption aside from
the standard devil fruit weakness the
powers of magumugunomi doesn't seem to
be weak against anything specific even
in a kainu's battle against aokiji who
should have some advantage over him due
to his ice powers he still came out
Victorious number
sevenomi model stadium
is a mythical Zone type devil fruit that
allows the user to transform into the
aussier dragon he was eaten by one of
the former Emperors of the sea kaido
besides the transformation this fruit
gives the user many supernatural
abilities the most out of any mythical
Zone fruit seen so far the most
prominent is the power to conjure flame
clouds with which the user can travel
through the air using them as footholds
Additionally the user can create and
control various elements the most
commonly seen one being fire sending a
scorching blast that the user breathes
out which can instantly decimate large
structures aside from the Flames the
user can also launch lightning bolts
while roaring and cutting blades of wind
while blowing on top of stirring up
strong fast rotating tornadoes beside
the ability to turn into a full Dragon
the user of can also transform into a
smaller human Dragon form which is much
more suited for close combat encounters
and even in this form the user retains
access to their Elemental attacks like
fire breath same as the previous fruit
on the list this one doesn't have any
specific weaknesses the only one being
that the user needs a lot of space to
transform into his full Dragon form and
is a bit Limited in enclosed spaces
number six gurugura Nomi Guru guronomi
is considered to be the strongest
paramecian type devil fruit in the
entire series allowing the user to
create strong vibrate stations in Quakes
it was initially eaten by Whitebeard but
upon his death its power was stolen by
teach the user of this fruit can
devastate entire islands with ease
create massive tsunamis and earthquakes
and even crack the air itself during the
Marine for an arc Whitebeard used the
powers of this fruit to fight against
multiple Admirals and although all of
his battles were interrupted he seemed
stronger than each one this fruit is
said to be powerful enough to destroy
the entire world and even some of the
highest ranking Marines were terrified
of what Whitebeard might do vice admiral
suru even stated that there would be no
safe place left in the world if the full
powers of guruguru Nomi were activated
we arguably never got to see its true
power yet as Whitebeard was undeniably
holding back due to his entire crew
being at Marine Ford and Blackbeard
lacked enough control to use it to its
full potential number 5. Yami Yami Nomi
yummy Yami Nomi is by many considered to
be the strongest logia type devil fruit
in the entire Series this fruit allows
the user to create and control Darkness
at will and it was eaten by the current
emperor of the sea Blackbeard this fruit
is considered unique even for a Logan
type and the ability he grants is said
to be the most evil the darkness this
fruit creates is visually demonstrated
as a black smoke-like substance
spreading out from the user's body since
darkness is said to devour and Crush
everything the user can use it to absorb
physical matters and attacks of any type
and even pull opponents towards him
similar to a black hole the user can
absorb things inside a Vortex which
Blackbeard used to suck an entire town
into himself and when he eventually
regurgitated it everything that was
expelled was reduced to scraps
interestingly living beings who are
absorbed seem to be able to survive but
become heavily wounded and left in Shock
by The Experience however what truly
separates this fruit from any other is
the unique ability to absorb and
completely nullify the powers of other
devil fruit users by simply touching
them all types via paramecia Zohan or
logia are affected by this number four
obey obey no me obey obey Nomi is a
paramecia type devil fruit that grants
the ability to freely manipulate and
remodel anyone or anything this fruit
was formally held by a certain famous
doctor but later consumed by Travel
Guard law by creating a spherical force
field centered around the user they gain
control over everything inside that
territory from living beings to
non-living objects as smoker put it the
obey opinomi's user becomes the surgeon
force field the operating room and those
caught inside are the patients on the
operating table obey Obi Nomi can
literally be used in hundreds of ways
but some ways law uses this fruit are
swapping the locations of two Targets
slicing people apart without actual
injury permanently taking out people's
organs without harm or even creating
electric shocks to destroy people's
bodies from the inside although this
fruit is not as offensively strong as
some of the other fruits on the list it
has one more unique ability that makes
it the ultimate devil fruit in exchange
for the user's own life can grant
somebody Eternal youth pretty much
making them Immortal this is why the
world government is willing to pay an
incredibly High Bounty of 5 billion
berries to anyone who can deliver this
fruit to them before we cover the
strongest devil fruit in the entire show
let's first quickly go over these two
mysterious fruits first okay these are
not yet fully confirmed but from what
we've seen in the recent chapters it
seems that these fruits will be amongst
the strongest in the series and the
first ones are the godose devil fruits
in chapter 1085 we've seen all five
Elders seemingly transforming into
animalistic creatures which Sabo has
described as demonic looking although
it's currently unknown if these
Transformations are the results of devil
fruit powers or something else entirely
many fans speculate that these are
probably some kind of Zoe and devil
fruits their place on the list is purely
hypothetical at this point but it's
certain that they're incredibly strong
another speculative entry on this list
is emu who we see transforming into a
massive beast-like creature capable of
consuming fire from what we've seen so
far emu doesn't appear to have a solid
body and instead he constantly morphs
and changes shapes like a shadow even
looking cartoonish sometimes like Luffy
in his gear 5 form they also controlled
what appeared to be a sharp pointed
Arrowhead or tentacle strong enough to
severely injure even the logia user Sabo
again emu's place on this list is purely
speculation but since they are expected
to be one piece's final villain they are
bound to be extraordinarily powerful
number one hido he don't know me model
Nika Hilo hidonomi model Nika is a
mythical Zone devil fruit that was eaten
by the one and only Monkey D Luffy this
fruit enables its user to transform into
a sun god giving them a rubbery-like
body if said that his powers are only
limited by the user's imagination for
some reason the world government is
terrified of this fruit and they've
tried to obtain it for over 800 years
without success the government even went
as far as to completely erase the Nika
fruit from history giving it the name
gomogomanomi and pretending it's just a
basic paramecia fruit once Luffy
awakened the fruit's true Powers he was
shown doing ridiculous things like
transforming into a giant cartoonishly
stretching his body bending the
environment around him and even
stretching lightning itself although the
powers of this root are absurd there is
some limitation to them for example
Olivia can't stretch things indefinitely
as they're bound to tear at some point
and the fruit puts enormous strain on
his body which leads to him turning into
an old man one street transformed click
on this video where we explained what
would happen if the strongest one-piece
characters had devil fruits